MARK STEYN IS DELIVERABLE      L
MARK STEYN IS DELIVERABLE      B
MARK STEYN IS DELIVERABLE      R
MARK STEYN IS DELIVERABLE      L
MARK STEYN IS DELIVERABLE      S
MARK STEYN IS DELIVERABLE      E
MARK STEYN IS DELIVERABLE      P
MARK STEYN IS DELIVERABLE      A
MARK STEYN IS DELIVERABLE      B
MARK STEYN IS DELIVERABLE      T
HE IS BEWILDERED.
TWO BIZARRE BUT TELLING STORIES
ABOUT OUR FUTURE AND AMERICA,
BOTH THE HEAD.
YOU MAY HAVE HEARD ABOUT A NEW
BATTLE BETWEEN CONGRESS AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
A GROUP OF CONGRESSIONAL --
DEMANDING THE DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL ROB ROSENSTEIN
RELEASED A SERIES OF DOCUMENTS
RELATED TO THE RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION.
THEY SAY THEY PLAN TO IMPEACH
ROSENSTEIN IF HE DOESN'T TURN
OVER THE INFORMATION.
SO FAR HE HAS DEFIANTLY REFUSED
TO DO THAT.
BEFORE YOU TUNE THIS OUT AS
ANOTHER PARTISAN ARCING DEBATE,
THE KIND THAT WASHINGTON
SPECIALIZES IN, HERE ARE THE
DETAILS.
THERE'S A LOT AT STAKE HERE, FAR
BEYOND THE SHORT-TERM POLITICAL
ADVANTAGE OF EITHER PARTY.
THE RUSSIA INVESTIGATION AS YOU
KNOW HAS COMPLETELY DOMINATED
THE BUSINESS OF GOVERNMENT SINCE
THE DAY TRUMP TOOK OFFICE.
IT'S ALL ANYONE IN WASHINGTON
CAN TALK OR THINK ABOUT.
NEVER MIND THE POTENTIAL WARS ON
THE HORIZON FOR THE FACT THAT
OUR OWN ECONOMY AND CULTURE ARE
CHANGING FASTER THAN ANYONE CAN
UNDERSTAND OR DIGEST.
IN D.C., ONLY THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION MATTERS, SO YOU
MAY WONDER WHAT IS THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION?
WHAT IS IT ABOUT?
WHAT EXACTLY IS HE
INVESTIGATING?
TURNS OUT, ALMOST NOBODY KNOWS
EXCEPT ROB ROSENSTEIN.
HE KNOWS, BUT HE WON'T TELL
CONGRESS.
LAST SUMMER HE WROTE A MEMO
DETAILING THE SCOPE OF THE
INVESTIGATION.
KEY PORTIONS OF THAT MEMO REMAIN
HIDDEN FROM VIEW.
CONGRESS WOULD LIKE TO SEE THEM
AND HAS EVERY RIGHT TO SEE THEM.
OUR CONSTITUTION REQUIRES OUR
ELECTED REPRESENTATIVES TO SUPER
SUPERVISE THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE.
WHY IS THAT?
SO THAT BUREAUCRATS REMAIN
ACCOUNTABLE TO VOTERS.
WE GIVE THEM GUNS, LET THEM
ARREST US AND SENTENCED TO
PRISON, ALLOW THEM TO BREAK INTO
OUR PRIVATE EMAIL ACCOUNTS, TAP
OUR PHONES.
THEY HAVE A LOT OF POWER.
IN RETURN THEY PROMISE NOT TO
MISUSE THAT POWER.
IF THERE'S ANY QUESTION ABOUT
THEIR HONESTY, WE GET THE CHECK.
THAT'S WHAT TRANSPARENCY IS.
GOVERNMENT BUREAUCRATS HATE
TRANSPARENCY.
THEY WOULD RATHER DO THEIR WORK
IN SECRET.
SECRECY IS THE SHIELD THAT
CONSIDER THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE INVESTIGATION INTO
RUSSIAN COLLUSION.
IT TOOK A YEAR TO COMPLETE.
THE FINAL REPORT RANKED 253
PAGES.
IF THE REST OF US COULDN'T
REALLY READ IT BECAUSE KEY FACTS
WERE MISSING.
JUST DOMINATE TRUMP ASSOCIATES
DID THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION SPY
ON DURING THE 2016 CAMPAIGN?
IT WOULD BE NICE TO KNOW THAT.
SORRY, IT'S REDACTED.
IS THERE ANY ACTUAL PROOF THAT
THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT DIRECTED
HACKING OF THE DNC AND
IF IT IS THEIRS THAT'S BEEN
REDACTED TOO.
REPORTS SAY THE FBI AGENTS WHO
INTERVIEWED MIKE FLYNN DIDN'T
BELIEVE HE WAS LYING, BUT WAIT,
MIKE FLYNN PLEADED GUILTY TO
LYING TO THOSE AGENTS AND HIS
LIFE WAS DESTROYED AS A RESULT.
HE SOLD HIS HOUSE TO RAISE MONEY
FOR HIS LEGAL DEFENSE.
SO WHAT'S GOING ON HERE?
WE DON'T KNOW.
THAT INFORMATION WAS REDACTED.
WHY WERE ALL THESE REACTIONS
MAY?
WE DON'T EVEN KNOW THAT.
WE ASKED, NO ONE WOULD TELL US.
AND THEN THERE'S THE FISA
APPLICATION TO SPY ON TRUMP
CAMPAIGN AIDE CARTER PAGE THAT
HASN'T BEEN RELEASED EITHER.
WE HAVE AMPLE REASON TO BELIEVE
THE APPLICATION MAY HAVE
FUNDAMENTALLY ILLEGITIMATE BASED
HEAVILY ON DISCREDITED PARTISAN
HEARSAY, THE DOSSIER.
JIM COMEY DENIES THIS OF COURSE.
HE HAS DENIED IT REPEATEDLY ON
HIS BOOK TOUR.
JUST THE OTHER DAY, HE NOTED,